este simple y sencillo templo en el
corazón de nueva delhi fue una vez
habitado por mahatma gandhi considerado
por muchos como el padre de la india
moderna y un poderoso símbolo mundial de
la resistencia no violenta
esta es la plataforma donde gandhi tenía
sus reuniones de oración este lugar se
convirtió en el centro neurálgico
político del país mientras él estaba
viven para muchos indios gandhi sigue
siendo un icono político celebrado por
su papel clave en la larga lucha contra
los colonos británicos aquí sus
pertenencias personales son
cuidadosamente preservadas y su retrato
es generado mañana y tarde
bach
los llamamos bajo el padre de la nación
es el símbolo de todas nuestras luchas
por la justicia social es la igualdad
económica e incluso hoy en día por el
medio ambiente
un modesto abogado del estado de gujarat
en el suroeste del país llegó a ser una
figura indispensable apreciada por su
pueblo y admirado por los jefes de
estado y las masas por igual incluso se
convirtió en una de las personalidades
más fotografiadas de su tiempo 73 años
después de la independencia la leyenda
de gandhi sigue estando muy viva en su
país pero aunque su imagen sea
omnipresente la sociedad india moderna
está cada vez más dividida sobre el
verdadero legado del mahatma era un
superhéroe para mí en esa época como
iron man o spider-man fue nuestro
protector y es gracias a él que nuestro
país es libre hoy gracias a él la gente
tiene comida que llevarse a la boca
aquellos que defienden los derechos
cívicos lo extrañan mucho sus ideas ya
no son tan relevantes actualmente
algunos dicen cosas buenas de él otros
dicen cosas malas no quiero ofender a
nadie hoy en día algunos no dudan en
denunciar abiertamente al padre de la
nación
este es el natural götze quien eliminó
al monstruo conocido como gandhi
nathuram godse el asesino de gun ya era
parte de una organización política de
extrema derecha el hindú más sabe creía
en la idea de una nación hindú le
reprochaba a gandhi la compasión que le
tenía a los muchos musulmanes del país
del asesinato de mahatma gandhi en 1948
sumió a la naciente democracia de india
en un profundo duelo götze fue condenado
a muerte y se convirtió en una figura
despreciada en la historia pero
actualmente su recuerdo está renaciendo
en un día hoy el hindú masaba alaba
abiertamente al asesino de gandhi quien
para ellos es un mártir y un patriota
fue mahatma gandhi quien orquestó la
participación de nuestro país y provocó
la muerte de cientos de miles de
personas es por eso que nathuram godse y
el hindú masada decidieron erradicar
este tipo de personas de nuestro planeta
los países occidentales lo adoran y lo
alaban pero entonces porque estos países
siguen comprando armas porque las hacen
si siguieran la filosofía de gandhi
tendrían que vivir con una
en la mano este tipo de discurso
provocativo
está lejos de ser algo de unos pocos en
el país actualmente muchos dirigentes
entre ellos el primer ministro narendra
modi amer homenajeado oficialmente a
figuras clave del hindú mahatma y su
ideología pero es difícil para el estado
criticar la figura de gandhi que es
mundialmente famoso y sigue siendo
extremadamente popular en libia para el
sociólogo sumet ma haksar la posición
del gobierno actual suele ser
contradictoria
[Música]
por un lado odian a gandhi por encima de
todo lo odian por la partición del país
para la derecha hindú la idea de una
gran india debería incluir lo que ahora
es pakistán y bangladesh
por otro lado realmente aprecian que
gandhi defenderá los valores
civilizacionales en los últimos años las
posiciones de gandhi también han sido
cada vez más criticadas por los grupos
que defienden las minorías y comunidades
oprimidas
gandhi siempre será recordado y siempre
será el padre de la
pero el padre de una nación particular
que viene de un pasado lleno de opresión
explotación hostil para los varias las
castas bajas y las mujeres en general
así que seguirá siendo el padre de esa
nación
la joven nación que gandhi ayudó a
moldear vive hoy en día una adolescencia
difícil permeada y dividida por las
castas la religión y la ideología
política pero en este vasto país de
menos de 75 años el legado de gandhi de
no-violencia y diversidad podría
sobrevivir hasta la adultez